good morning Hank it's Monday May 5th oh
shoot
[Music]
stupid stupid stupid um Hank the
nerdfighters and I we uh forgot your
birthday well actually a bunch of
nerdfighters remembered your birthday
links in the sidebar and I guess since
your birthday is today we haven't
technically forgotten it but we didn't
come together to use our cognitive
surplus to make you something awesome
oh god Hank I can't believe you got all
those people to blenderize birthday
cakes and eat them for me and then when
your birthday comes nothing nerdfighters
we've got to do something or Hank is
never gonna forgive us I mean if we
don't put together something awesome
Frank's birthday he's probably gonna
drop out of the channel entirely we're
gonna have to call it vlog brother and
then no no like our show because
everyone knows that Hank is the more
popular brother oh boy okay okay we've
got to do something awesome there's only
one problem I don't have any awesome
ideas right now I mean I was gonna try
to make you a party boy or solo even
though I'm totally tone deaf but then
when I got here to my hotel in Atlanta I
was like to the concierge hey um where
do you get all the party blowers and he
was like sir I'm not legally allowed to
answer that question by the way Hank my
hotel in Atlanta
very fancy in fact there's only one
shortcoming twin beds
what is this nanny's house okay okay
everybody stay calm
Hank is not going to leave the
vlogbrothers Channel he's still my
brother he's not that mad at me god I
hope he's not mad at me okay here's
we're gonna do first everybody wish Hank
a happy birthday in comments then
everybody tell me a really really good
idea like an idea that is distinctly
better than blender izing birthday cakes
and eating them I will be back here
tomorrow that's right you heard me
tomorrow for the first time in the last
16 months I'm going to make videos on
back-to-back days and in that video I'm
going to announce what we're gonna do
and when we're gonna do it by the way
nerdfighters thanks for all your
punishment suggestions I think we've
settled on one oh and nerdfighters by
the way if you live in or near Grand
Rapids Michigan on Thursday at 6:30 you
can come to a library to hear me and
Maureen Johnson and
green talking stuff details in the video
info Hank I'm really sorry that we
forgot your birthday so sorry that my
voice was cracked
anyway happy birthday Hank even though
I'm not totally convinced that you're
getting older because everyone knows
that awesome is immortal
Earth Day - Hank happy birthday - Hank
we forgot to do something awesome for
the occasion but we'll make up for it
next week happy birthday - Hank